HAPPEN ANYMORE.
>> Tammy: MORE WORK TO DO.
GREAT, THANK YOU, JONATHAN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT.
KRIS KOBACH IS THE KANSAS
SECRETARY OF STATE.
HE JOINS US NOW.
YOU ARE A MAN, YOU HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR
QUITE SOME TIME, FOR YEARS, YOU
KNOW WHAT THE SITUATION IS, THIS
IS NOT UNFAMILIAR TO YOU,
EITHER.
CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE, REALLY,
AS PEOPLE MIGHT WANT TO BLAME
FOR SHUTDOWN, BUT THIS IS REALLY
CHAOS THAT IS UNFOLDING AND AN
OVERWHELMED CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION FOR US,
OVERWHELMED I.C.E. PERHAPS,
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONTAINED, IF
YOU WILL COME OF A CERTAIN COURT
DECISIONS, ET CETERA THEY CAN
AND CANNOT DO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON IN
EL PASO ENTERED THE PEOPLE THERE
BE CONCERN ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING?
>> FIRST OF ALL, YOU ARE CORRECT
WHEN YOU SUGGEST THIS IS NOT
BECAUSE OF THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
ENFORCEMENT AND REMOVAL
OPERATIONS OF I.C.E., THE
DIVISION THAT HANDLES THIS TYPE
OF DUTY, THEIR ESSENTIAL
EMPLOYEES, THEY ARE WORKING AT
FULL STEAM REGARDLESS OF THE
SHUTDOWN.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME PUBLIC
AFFAIRS OFFICERS WHO NORMALLY
CONTACT THE PRESS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT HE MIGHT NOT BE
WORKING.
BUT IT'S NOT CAUSED BY THE
SHUTDOWN.
SECONDLY, ALTHOUGH THE NUMBERS
THIS WEEK IN EL PASO ARE LARGE,
AND LARGER THAN NORMAL, PEOPLE
SHOULD BE AWARE THAT THERE ARE,
IF YOU LOOK NATIONALLY,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE BEING
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES
WHO ARE ASYLUM-SEEKERS, NOT
NECESSARILY WORTHY OF ASYLUM,
BUT CLAIMING THAT THEY ARE EVERY
MONTH.
SO THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM.
THIS NUMBER SHOULD SHOCK YOU.
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS, THE
NUMBER OF ASYLUM CLAIMS IN THE
UNITED STATES SYSTEM HAS GONE UP
2000%.
THERE ARE ALMOST 800,000 ASYLUM
CASES PENDING IN THE IMMIGRATION
APARTMENT.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE ARE
NOT LEGITIMATE.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN CLAIMS, WELL
OVER 90% ARE GOING TO BE DENIED.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN CLOSE TO BEING
LEGITIMATE CLAIMS OF ASYLUM.
ASYLUM REQUIRES THAT YOUR
GOVERNMENT'S BACK RIM IS
PERSECUTING YOU AND THAT YOU
HAVE A WELL-FOUNDED FEAR OF
BEING HURT BECAUSE HER
MEMBERSHIP IN    IN A PURCHASE A
CARLOS JOHNSON TO SOCIAL GOOD.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, I HAVE GANGS
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD.
THIS ASYLUM LOOPHOLE HAS BECOME
A MASSIVE LOOPHOLE THAT IS
CAUSING A HUGE PROBLEM FOR THE
WHOLE SYSTEM.
IT IS A BIG PROBLEM.
THIS IS JUST A SYMPTOM.
>> Tammy: WE ARE LETTING THESE
PEOPLE ARE.
OF COURSE, PRESUMING THEY WILL
COME BACK.
THIS IS THE OLD GAME TOGETHER
COURT HEARING.
AND THEN THEY NEVER SHOW UP.
BUT WE ALSO LEARNED A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO FROM SECRETARY
NIELSEN, THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, THAT WE HAVE
AN ARRANGEMENT WITH MEXICO NOW
THAT THEY WOULD HOLD PEOPLE WHO
ARE LOOKING FOR ASYLUM, UNTIL WE
CAN ADJUDICATE THEM.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS REALLY
GOING TO HAPPEN?
OR DO YOU THINK THAT WE ARE
STILL -- IS THE PRESIDENT STILL
GOING TO HAVE TO GO AND GET THIS
DONE THROUGH THE COURTS, WHICH
CLEARLY SEEM TO BE RESISTANT TO
HIM BEING ABLE TO CONTROL THE
BORDER?
>> WELL, A LITTLE OF BOTH.
I THINK THAT WHAT SECRETARY
NIELSEN ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK IS A
BIG -- IT'S NOT A FIRST STEP,
IT'S A BIG STEP OF THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T YET CROSSED INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IN EL PASO,
THEY WERE ALREADY IN
UNITED STATES WHEN THEY WERE
APPREHENDED, MANY OF THEM,
ANYWAY.
FOR THOSE PEOPLE, WHAT DHS NEEDS
TO BE READ AWAY, IS TO FINALIZE
A PROPOSED REGULATION THAT THEY
PROMULGATED BACK IN
SEPTEMBER, AND THAT REGULATION
WILL OVERRIDE WHAT IS CALLED THE
FLORES SETTLEMENT, WHICH IS BY
RERELEASING THESE PEOPLE, AND
ALLOWS THE DETENTION OF COMPLETE
FAMILY UNITS TOGETHER UNTIL THE
CASE IS ADJUDICATED.
WE GOT TO GET THAT.
THERE IS NO TIME TO WASTE.
>> Tammy: THAT IS THE